et si on était bientôt capable grâce à
l'intelligence artificielle de
reconstituer la personnalité des morts
non vous n'êtes pas dans un épisode de
black mirror mais bien sur une chaîne de
vulgarisation scientifique parlé avec
césar beaucoup d'historiens en rêve et
bien c'est pas forcément inenvisageable
bienvenue dans l'ère de la nécromancie
digital mais d'abord avant de ranimer
nos ancêtres qui bat roupies
tranquillement dans leur sarcophage
laissez moi vous présenter votre futur
couchette le matelas hybride de la
marque emma et masques autorise la vidéo
du jour en vous proposant pas de très
belles remises sur les produits de
literie en ce moment il ya des soldes
qui court jusqu'au 19 juillet vous avez
jusqu'à 50% sur le site et avec ce code
là vous avez 10 % additionnel la marque
m'envoyer le matelas hybrides ils en ont
deux l'original et l'hybride pour que le
test est alors
bonheur j'ai une grosse sciatique quand
je fouille et quand j'étais archéo et
donc la literie chez moi c'est tout un
programme donc ici on est clairement sur
un soutien ferme avec une bonne couche
bien moelleuse en accueille oui les
termes techniques je gère non mais je
vous dis je suis hyper calais en literie
la livraison est très rapide il arrive
rouler sous vide il suffit tout
simplement de découper le plastique et
de le laisser tranquille ans déplier si
vous hésitez à acheter un matelas en
ligne sachez que ce matelas hybride a
reçu le prix ufc que choisir 2021 et que
l'autre matelas originale a tout
simplement été la meilleure vente en
france depuis deux ans on ce sont de
très bons produits vous avez une
garantie évidemment de dix ans une
livraison et de retour gratuit et vous
avez même une période d'essai donc
vraiment vous avez aucun risque je vous
en donne le code ici pour profiter de
10% additionnels aux réductions sur le
site et on enchaîne avec la vidéo du
jour
revenons à nos moutons électriques les
archéologues doivent très souvent ça
rappelle alors mémoire ils apprennent
par coeur des typologies pour connaître
la forme des objets savoir identifier
les poteries les silex taillés où les
inscriptions au premier coup d'oeil et
gagner du temps sur le terrain mais
depuis quelques temps les archéologues
font appel à de nouveaux outils pour
assister leurs mémoires certains
logiciels font aujourd'hui un travail
extraordinaire pour compléter l'analyse
des chercheurs voire pour restituer ce
qui n'existe plus et on va en parler en
réalité depuis son origine l'archéologie
s'est toujours intéressé aux nouvelles
technologies pour trouver davantage de
vestiges et pour livrer des
interprétations plus précise les
archéologues se sont aidés des
microscopes les plus performants de
sonars magnétique dernier cri ou de
robots sous-marins ultra perfectionnés
on a d'ailleurs parlé dans des vidéos
plus ancienne de plusieurs ces
innovations comme l'idaho où la
tomographie qui donne des résultats
spectaculaires aujourd'hui je voudrais
faire le point sur l'une des dernières
techniques dont se sont emparés les
archéologues l'intelligence artificielle
mais avant de voir les applications
possibles pour l'archéologie il faut
expliquer rapidement le principe de
cette méthode ce qu'on appelle le dip
learning pour mais étant donné que c'est
pas mon domaine de prédilection et que
je m'intéresse surtout aux applications
pour trouver des vieilleries ou à part
entrer dans tous les détails en
informatique vous l'avez compris le
diplôme ning appuyant français
apprentissage profond a émergé depuis
une dizaine d'années ça consiste à faire
analyser un programme informatique des
données de manière autonome cela est
rendu possible grâce à une architecture
complexe de réseaux de neurones virtuel
qu'on appelle convolution neuronale
network cnn inspiré du fonctionnement du
cerveau humain ils permettent de faire
passer l'information à travers
différentes couches de neurones et de
gagner au fur et à mesure en précision
voilà pour la théorie je vous rassure il
ya très peu de personnes qui maîtrisent
les détails de cette technologie nous on
veut simplement comprendre le principe
les différentes couches de neurones
artificiels réagissent à différents
types d'informations une première peut
être sensible au contraste élevé dans
une image une deuxième à une certaine
couleur une troisième à la essence de
courbes etc et les dernières couches
seront enfin sensible aux combinaisons
entre les caractéristiques qu'on vient
de citer l'ordinateur sera ainsi capable
de reconnaître et de traiter des données
très complexe mais là où le dip learning
est particulièrement intéressant c'est
qu'au lieu de laisser aux humains le
soin de programmer les bons critères sur
lesquels l'ordinateur doit s'appuyer
pour accomplir sa tâche on peut
aujourd'hui faire en sorte que
l'ordinateur détermine lui même les
critères pertinents et ainsi éviter les
biais d' analyse par exemple si vous
apprenez à votre ordinateur à
reconnaître une photo d'éléphants en lui
disant qu'il doit chercher un machin
fripé avec de grandes oreilles vous
risquez de vous retrouver avec des
imprévus ledit planning consiste plutôt
à donner à votre logiciel des milliers
de photos avec et sans éléphants et à le
laisser déterminer la meilleure manière
de les reconnaître c'est pour ça que je
vous parlait d'autonomie tout à l'heure
cette méthode a déjà donné des résultats
spectaculaires en 2015 le logiciel de
jeu de go alpha go à populariser le
diplôme ning auprès du grand public et
peut-être que certains d'entre vous ont
entendu parler du dip learning à cette
occasion contrairement au jeu d'échecs
les programmeurs à des beaucoup de mal à
apprendre un ordinateur à jouer au gault
un jeu très anciens originaires de chine
avant 2015 aucun programme informatique
n'avait encore battu deux joueurs
professionnels alors que cet exploit a
été réalisé des 97 pour les échecs par
les logiciels ibm
contrairement à ibm l'entreprise
britannique deep mind a conçu un
logiciel qui s'est perfectionné en
partant de zéro et en jouant au go
contre lui-même les concepteurs du
logiciel ne lui ont appris que les
règles du jeu c'est tout
c'est en analysant ses propres parties
et les milliers de variantes possibles
selon la méthode du dip learning khalfa
go a enfin pu écraser les plus grands
champions humains en quelques mois plus
personne ne pouvait rivaliser avec le
logiciel
on le voit l'intelligence artificielle à
travers le diplôme ning permet non
seulement de traiter des données très
rapidement et surtout de déterminer
elle-même la bonne méthode pour résoudre
le problème qu'on lui pose avec une
efficacité totalement inédite et ça
ouvre dans tous les champs de recherche
des possibilités phénoménale et les
archéologues bien sûr n'ont pas laissé
passer cette chance parmi les premières
applications de cette intelligence
artificielle
il y à la reconnaissance automatisée des
vestiges avec le projet arc aide ces
fameux réseaux artificielle de neurones
ont été utilisés dès 2016 par les
archéologues pour reconstituer
automatiquement la forme des poteries à
partir de simples fragments en
constituant un corpus de poterie scanner
en 3d les chercheurs ont livré à
l'ordinateur une immense base de données
dans laquelle il pouvait chercher des
critères communs et ainsi identifier
rapidement les nouveautés sont poterie
dans les années qui ont suivi ces
compétences ont aussi été utilisés pour
reconnaître les amphores dans les
photographies de prospection sous marine
mais aussi pour trier de la poterie à
partir de sa texture ou encore pour
identifier à coup sûr les traces de
coupe sur les ossements ces méthodes
permettent d'analyser des données à une
vitesse inégalée et ainsi d'épargner aux
chercheurs des milliers d'heures de
traitement d'image grâce aux diplômes
ning les archéologues de l'université de
rennes ont ainsi pu traiter des
centaines de milliers d'image lidar vous
savez ces lasers qui passe à travers le
couvert forestier ils ont pu détecter
des cas néolithique dans le morbihan
bien plus loin nous dans les steppes
d'asie centrale ce traitement automatisé
appliquée aux photos satellites a permis
de repérer des dizaines de nouvelles
tombes de la culture ça qu'un date entre
le 7e et le iiième siècle avant
jésus-christ publié en 2019 dans le
journal of archaeological science
cette étude montre qu'en cherchant des
éléments assez simple en l'occurrence
des tombes circulaire l'assistance de
l'intelligence artificielle permet de
faire gagner un temps considérable
la prospection d'une zone si vaste et si
peu peuplée aurait demandé des années
avec les techniques habituelles donc
vous l'avez compris les applications
sont presque illimitées dans le domaine
de la reconnaissance automatisée non
seulement aucun chercheur ne peut
rivaliser avec la vitesse de calcul d'un
ordinateur mais en plus ce logiciel a
tendance à moins se tromper les
archéologues s'en sont rendu compte dans
la reconnaissance du sexe des squelettes
cette analyse qui est faite d'après des
critères théoriquement objectif se
révèle parfois biaisé quand elle est
réalisée par l'oeil humain les
chercheurs peuvent parfois sur
interpréter certains aspects anatomique
ceux qui trompent leur jugement un
défaut que n'ont pas ses logiciels froid
et imperturbable en toutes circonstances
l'étude publiée en 2019 dans le journal
of forensic legal médecine l'a bien
montré avec ledit planning apparaît même
l'espoir de percer le mystère de
certaines écritures toujours non
déchiffrer c'est le cas de la
mystérieuse écriture de la vallée de
l'indus les deux chercheurs indiens qui
ont ainsi initié un programme en 2017
pour essayer de résoudre cette énigme
pour l'instant on est loin de
propositions de traduction il s'agit
surtout de classes et des inscriptions
est de le reconnaître de manière
automatisée mais ça peut conduire à des
progrès significatifs dans les années
qui viennent d'ailleurs c'est peut-être
dans le domaine des écritures anciennes
que l'intelligence artificielle a le
plus à apporter dans un article paru
cette année en mars 2022 une équipe
internationale de chercheurs présente le
dernier né des logiciels intelligents
appliquée à l'épigraphie alors
l'épigraphie c'est l'étude des textes
anciens c'est une discipline qui
déchiffre les inscriptions et tente d'en
donner la meilleure traduction possible
ses textes sont inscrits sur des
supports dur donc comme la pierre ou le
métal d'accord à lyon d'un très bel
exemple avec les tables claudiennes
bomba le boulot des épigraphistes ces
deux
ça voilà c'est un métier mais ça ne
garantit pas forcément une conservation
idéal les épigraphistes doivent donc non
seulement avoir une excellente
connaissance des langues anciennes et de
leur évolution mais aussi être capable
de combler les manques de certains
textes abîmé pourrons reconstituer le
message originel pour ça il ya des
compilations d'inscription régulièrement
publiées et qui constitue un immense
corpus dans lequel aller piocher des
comparaisons c'est stockés dans des
bibliothèques d'archéologie ce sont des
livres que le grand public n'ouvre
jamais un ce sont les matériaux bruts de
la recherche je vous rassure aujourd'hui
il ya beaucoup de corpus qui sont
disponibles en ligne via des portails de
revues et des sites spécialisés les
habits graphiste bas ce sont donc des
personnes qui sont habitués à ingurgité
une quantité de textes de dédicaces de
monuments des épitaphes et des fragments
de discours pour se constituer une base
de données personnelles c'est donc avant
tout dans leurs connaissances et dans
les références dont ils ont entendu
parler qu'il pioche pour interpréter les
nouveaux textes mais évidemment par
l'érudition et les morts humaines elles
ont leurs limites et c'est là bien
entendu qu'intervient l'intelligence
artificielle dans cet article collectif
publié dans la revue nature's et
présenter un nouvel outil et son énorme
potentiel et d'ailleurs c'est l'un
d'entre vous qui me l'a transmis et ça
m'a donné envie de faire cette vidéo
donc merci beaucoup à cette personne je
ne sais plus comment vous appelez vous
vous reconnaîtrez peut-être merci
beaucoup baptisé ithaca il se concentre
pour l'instant sur les inscriptions
grecque il doit notamment être capable
de restaurer les éléments manquants
d'attribuer une origine géographique et
même une datation au texte ce qui est
particulièrement intéressant parce que
sur ces supports la datation au carbone
14 par exemple ne fonctionne pas les
performances de cet outil sont déjà
remarquable puisqu'il permet de
restaurer avec une précision de 62% les
lacunes d'un texte de les dater à 30 ans
près et atteint même 71% d'exactitude
sur l'origine géographique ithaca est un
outil gratuit qui fonctionne grâce aux
efforts faits depuis des années pour
numériser de très nombreux textes et
mutualiser la recherche le logiciel a pu
étudier plus de 78 mille inscriptions et
c'est grâce à ce répertoire d'origine
qui peut ensuite extrait paulet et
interpréter les nouveaux textes qu'on
lui présente ithaca est donc capable de
proposer une liste de mots manquants une
région d'origine et une datation selon
leur plus grande probabilité respectives
la présentation synthétique des
résultats sous forme de graphiques et de
cartes est aussi conçu pour faciliter le
travail c'est donc un complément
précieux à ce que les auteurs de
l'article appelle le répertoire
mnémonique des chercheurs autrement dit
leur mémoire et leur capacité d analyse
je vous rassure il n'est pas question
pour l'instant de remplacer les
chercheurs le logiciel seul n'est pas en
mesure de livrer des interprétations
complexe il s'agit plutôt d'un super
assistant qui peut opérer un tri
ultrarapide ithaca devrait donc
permettre de mieux comprendre l'histoire
grecque dans les années à venir les
développements futurs de l'intelligence
artificielle en archéologie sont donc
incertains qui sait ce qu'elle sera
capable d'accomplir demain pour
l'instant il s'agit surtout l'identifier
plus vite que les humains de les aider
dans le traitement des données il est
probable que dans les prochaines
décennies les programmes intelligents
pourront aller toujours plus loin dans
l'interprétation reconstituer des textes
toujours plus fragmentaire reconnaître
des morceaux d'objets toujours plus
petits en 2020 shawn graham qui est
professeur à l'université de carleton au
canada a publié un livre intitulé un
agent mode digital archaeology dans
lequel il postule que ces nouvelles
technologies pour ont pratiquement
ramené à la vie les sociétés du passé la
notion d'enchantement qu'ils utilisent
et donc à entendre comme une émotion
mais à la fois comme une forme de magie
il s'agit de réanimer les morts en
faisant parler les artefacts les
archéologues devenant en quelque sorte
des apprentis nécromancien
g pense qu en nourrissant un logiciel de
l'intégralité des écrits de cicéron par
exemple on pourra bientôt créer une
émulation de ce personnage historique en
le faisant parler en donnant logiciels
des informations sur les conditions de
vie des croyances le climat on peut même
imaginer obtenir une personnalité
virtuel complexe et crédible donner à
manger les commentaires sur la guerre
des gaules à votre ordinateur et ils
vous sortira bientôt un jules césar avec
qui discuter bien entendu cette
simulation n'aura pas grand chose à voir
avec la réalité du passé ce sera un
modèle simplifié un mort vivant en
primitif mais g ne doute pas qu'ils
seront de plus en plus complexes avec le
perfectionnement de ces techniques cette
nécromant signifie talent à des intérêts
pour la recherche mais aussi des
applications déroutante qui ont pu être
explorés par la science fiction dans
black mirror par exemple
si le monde des sciences humaines et
celui des sciences d'informatique ne
communique souvent pas beaucoup une plus
grande collaboration semble
indispensable les idées les plus
stimulantes viennent très souvent de
l'association de plusieurs points de vue
l'archéologie l'a montré depuis très
longtemps en associant des architectes
des artisans les ingénieurs des
ethnologues des médecins ou des
botanistes pour exploiter les données
issues des fouilles les recherches de
l'intelligence artificielle sont sans
doute le prochain défi qui s'offre aux
archéologues alors avec quel personnage
historique aimeriez-vous discuter
vous pouvez retrouver les sources de
tous les articles utilisés pour réaliser
cette vidéo dans la barque
d'informations je vous remercie d'avoir
regardé cette vidéo je remercie emma qui
a sponsorisé cette vidéo je vous
rappelle qu emma vous offre 10 %
supplémentaires sur leurs soldes qui
court jusqu'au 19 juillet profitez-en
pour vous payer un super nouveau lit
vraiment ça vaut le coup c'est ici dans
le petit est là dans le lien directement
sur la base d'informations je vous
remercie et je vous souhaite un très bel
été parce que c'est la dernière vidéo de
l'été je retrouve en septembre
[Musique]
m